what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so a lot of people don't know this
happened and in fact I didn't even
really know this happened I was just
going through and looking for like all
the different taients for for a blackest
night and I just kind of stumbled across
this like a Red Lanterns superboy-prime
and it's crazy the way this happens so
we do a little bit of history here so a
superboy-prime was a was an interesting
character back when he first popped up I
mean we've talked about how he came from
like earth prime which was basically the
real world before crisis on Infinite
Earths the problem was that crisis on
Infinite Earths got rid of the
multiverse and it destroyed his universe
along with it and so he was kind of
shuffled off to this paradise dimension
it was supposed to be heaven and the
result was that he came back some 20
years later by Geoff Johns with regards
to the Infinite Crisis story now the way
that he was done the way that he was
written by Geoff Johns is he was
designed to be the comic book reader
looking at the world of comic books and
it was literally this idea and I would
even go as far as to say that
superboy-prime represented Geoff Johns
himself in the sense that it was
basically John's looking at the way
heroes used to be before crisis on
Infinite Earths and saying they've lost
their way super heroes are darker
they're grittier and so with those
waters being murky superboy-prime in the
Paradise dimension basically just
watched everything unfold and as he
began to watch things he began to
realize that because of the fact that he
read comic books in the real world in an
hour world basically and the superheroes
that he remembers are not the way
superheroes are now he basically came to
the conclusion that the superheroes are
not superheroes
they're basically bad guys masquerading
as good guys that was the whole
motivation behind his character during
the events of Infinite Crisis now of
course in the process he became a bad
guy himself I mean he literally killed
however many superheroes it took to
Superman and 50 Green Lantern's to stop
him but it was still a pretty epic
conflict the issue with this was that
once superboy-prime was defeated DC
didn't really know what to do with him
because he came from an earth that
didn't exist anymore this went into
Sinestro Corps war which we already
covered on my channel of course we
covered both Infinite Crisis and
Sinestro Corps war and you'll find both
of those in the Green Lantern playlist
down in the description but the idea was
that superboy-prime basically joined the
Sinestro Corps he was effectively
brought back because of the fact that he
instilled so much fear in people he was
a perfect candidate for the yellow
lanterns the problem again was that once
the story finished he was
kind of shuffled off to the multiverse
never to be seen or heard from again but
because of the fact that Infinite Crisis
brought the multiverse back and Final
Crisis made the heroes aware of the fact
that the multiverse was back what ended
up happening is DC brought him back in a
story called a final crisis legion of
three worlds now this was designed for
the purpose of basically sending him
back to his own universe and the way
that it played out it was basically him
just fighting a version of himself from
like the 31st century or something along
those lines and that was really about it
but what the conflict did is it
basically created this sort of paradox
in the sense that if he's fighting
himself did it kind of just resulted in
this massive you know expanse of energy
or something along those lines
some in comic book explanation that just
made sense at the time and I just
shuffled him back to his own universe
now that's where this picks up because
the earth prime that exists after
Infinite Crisis is basically the exact
same earth crime that existed before
crisis on Infinite Earths because the
universe is used so infrequently DC
could get away with it earth prime as it
existed before crisis on Infinite Earths
earth crime as it exists now these are
the only two times we've ever seen it so
DC could kind of do whatever they wanted
to it's not like they had to basically
make things match up because characters
come from that universe all the time it
didn't work that way and so what is up
happening is that superboy-prime
basically picks up in his home universe
now what didn't keep in mind here is
that because of the fact that he had
basically been transported from the weir
world into the world of comics his life
everything that he had done was recorded
in comic book form and so that's exactly
how this plays out the friends and
family of superboy-prime
now know what he's done they basically
watched him become a villain the result
is that they knew what he was capable of
once they basically realized that he has
powers and that once he returns back to
the real world
he'll still have those powers and
absolutely terrified them but in the
case of superboy-prime
he's literally reading adventure comics
he's reading this story where
essentially it's the events of blackest
night but he also doesn't know was gonna
happen he's reading the story about
himself and that's what's so weird about
this is because it's basically this idea
that he is visited by alexander luthor
now of course the whole point behind all
this is it really this kind of runs over
a Zorgon story to a degree a lot of the
stuff that we just covered but alexander
luthor was basically a version of Lex
Luthor from a different universe where
you know he was basically a good guy he
was where
the superheroes were bad guys and Lex
Luthor was the good guy the result is
that during the events of Infinite
Crisis he switched over to being a bad
guy ultimately he was killed by the
Joker because Alexander Luthor wouldn't
let the joke her into you know his group
of villains whatever it is but what
ended up happening here is that when the
Black Lantern rings showed up on earth
they immediately sort of bond themselves
to a litany of other people one of whom
was Alexander Luthor now remember for
those of you guys who are just joining
us in our story about blackest night
this is basically the rise of the Black
Lantern Corps it's this prophecy of
blackest night coming to fruition from
the time that green lantern rebirth back
in 2000 and whatever written by Geoff
Johns was first introduced all the way
up to right now it's been this idea that
there's been this prophecy called the
prophecy of blackest night that there
will be all these other Lantern cores
that will start to rise up and it will
essentially instigate this war of light
but while that war of light is going on
the black lanterns will rise and the
black lanterns will basically begin
converting everybody to the Black
Lantern Corps the core that represents
death and in turn they will kill all
sentient life which means the emotional
spectrum will cease to exist and all
life will die within the DC Universe so
it's really like the end of times story
it's an apocalyptic story but the
overall goal here the overall concept
here is that because Alexander Luthor
was the person who held such a close
connection to superboy-prime
because Alexander Luthor was the one
that pushed him along this path of
becoming a bad guy this basically
creates a scenario where if anybody is
going to try to convert superboy-prime
it's gonna be Alexander Luthor this also
hits the idea that the Superboy Prime's
parents are absolutely terrified of them
now the other implication here is that
he had basically lashed out at his
girlfriend Lori what they simply say is
after what he did to Lori so we kind of
have to assume that that's true that he
had lashed out in a fit of anger and
attacked his girlfriend but regardless
of the circumstances it's put both Lori
herself and his parents in a climate of
complete and total fear all the time
because they don't know if he's just
going to freak out and attack them
possibly kill them they don't know
exactly what it is that he's gonna do
but showing up in this comic book store
and freaking out because issue number
five isn't out yet and he wants to know
what happens with the story not being
released the only thing you could do is
go on the internet and look up spoilers
now of course this results in the
arrival of
Alexander Luthor and again that's kind
of the cool thing here because what this
does is it begins hitting at the nature
of superboy-prime
in terms of how some people viewed him
as well as how he was written as a
character and the way it happens is that
for reasons that are never explained
Alexander Luthor just reinstates
superboy-prime powers now it's kind of a
weird scenario because the way it was
left off in terms of him being shunted
back to his own universe after the
events of Final Crisis legion of three
worlds the implication was that his
powers would return and it seems like
they flared up occasionally but he's
never returned to like his
superboy-prime self and so with
alexander luthor doing whatever it is
that he does and this basically sets
superboy-prime back to the way he was
and that's cool because this leads to a
real world fight in the DC Multiverse
between superboy-prime and alexander
luthor so what's going on right here is
equivalent to you walking down to your
local comic book store and seeing
superboy-prime and alexander luthor
beating the crap out of one another but
again this also hits up the nature of
his character the biggest issue that
people have that that a lot of people
have with superboy-prime as you started
out is a great character and then
immediately progressed to just your
stereotypical angsty teenager but in the
midst of all this what we end up doing
is get our first introductions into the
idea of Black Lantern rings bonding two
living hosts
but so far the black lantern rings only
pick up on individuals who are dead or
at least who have died somewhere along
along the notion of a Black Lantern ring
bonding itself to a human host shouldn't
necessarily be possible because a person
who's alive cannot rise from the dead
but that's the basis of blackest night
the idea of converting the living to the
dead so again that's why I sort of sort
of interesting but of course with
alexander luthor also comes all these
other members of the Black Lantern Corps
and it's basically just people that
superboy-prime is killed over the course
of his life of being a vigilante and
attacking people and so on and so forth
but when this Black Lantern ring tries
to bond itself to superboy-prime what
should happen is the ring should
dominate if that's what's supposed to
happen that's how it's supposed to take
place but with all these things being
told to Superboy prong he's a caveat
that he's basically just this MacGuffin
he's a plot device he serves no real
useful purpose in the DC landscape his
purpose was to serve a story and then
nobody ever knew what to do with him
ever since it literally turns him on his
head because initially the Black Lantern
ring bonds to him but in his anger and
in his power he starts cycling through
all these emotions until he overpowers
the Black Lantern ring and turns it into
a Red Lantern ring and that's something
that I do not believe we've ever seen
before now a lot of this is really
designed to hit home at what we've
already talked about with regards to
superboy-prime this idea that
superboy-prime is just a plot device so
riders will just write him however they
want to in order to write whatever story
it is they want to write and that's
really what kind of goes on here the
idea the superboy-prime is so incredibly
powerful that he can dominate a Black
Lantern ring and he can force the Black
Lantern ring to be something else that's
just the power that he possesses and if
you guys notice here while this story
predates DC rebirth by you know several
years this basically gives us this sort
of look at like what the phantom ring
does for those of you guys who are not
familiar with the Green Lantern or the
Green Lantern mythos and DC rebirth
there is a lantern ring that's only
recently been introduced it's a new
concept and it's called a phantom ring
and instead of all the other rings
choosing people where like a person has
to be able to overcome fear to use a
Green Lantern ring where a person has to
be able to instill fear to use a yellow
Lantern ring the phantom rain just
allows a person to use whatever you know
part of the emotional spectrum they want
to it would be like if anybody could
walk up and just lift Thor's hammer and
so because of this
phantom rings cycles through all the
different aspects of the emotional
spectrum based on whatever emotion the
wearer is feeling at the time now the
phantom ring requires the wear to be an
absolute control of their emotions 100%
of the time less they lose control which
is exactly what we saw happen but the
way that you see things playing out
right now with superboy-prime is exactly
the way the Phantom ring works he cycles
through all these emotions because one
he's afraid that Alexander Luthor is
right he does not want Alexander Luthor
to be right because he wants to be the
center of the universe he loves the idea
of being the center of the universe but
he also loves the idea of Laurie lemon
of the woman that he has in his life he
has the willpower to overcome all these
different obstacles he's angry at the
fact that maybe Alexander Luthor is
right he feels compassion because of the
fact that he has guilt for the things
that he's done he starts cycling through
all these emotions and it's really cool
to see because it's literally this
massive swarm of power that just totally
obliterates Alexander Luthor and all the
other black Lantern's the problem with
this is that this is it this is really
all there is just because of the fact
that once all this happens he literally
just destroys the Black Lantern ring
with all the power that he has and the
result is that he's actually met by the
arrival of Laurie lemon and again that's
kind of the crazy thing here is because
she basically pops up and says well hey
they sent me to tell you that there's
there's nothing wrong with anything you
know that everything is gonna be okay
that they're going to basically make
sure that you're left alone and you're
never bothered again but what
superboy-prime doesn't realize is that
Laurie lemons wearing a black Lantern
ring so she's basically a Black Lantern
hell-bent on converting him into one so
again that's where the story ends it
ruined just kind of stops all of a
sudden like it just ends and that's
really about it there's no winding down
there's no things sort of wrapping up it
just stops and that's kind of
disappointing so I don't know what
happens next I can't tell you guys what
one is I'm taking place next but with
that being said guys we're gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end if
you are new here to comment explain and
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the Rob port if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]